spawns
and
now the question is whether black is
going to be capturing
the f pawn and
trying to save himself which i don't
think there is too much practical chance
for black either way but maybe kind of
keep those two past pawns on the board
it means that black has to be moving
back then king g3 and immediately white
is capturing
already one of the points okay so we we
have it on the board yeah this is on the
board bishop a h5 a5 actually it was a
very good try by
magnus because now the problem is that
even this position
with
if the d4 pawn would not exist it's also
winning because there is three
empty
files between the two pawns and that's a
win okay but let's see what how he did
he went b6
which i don't understand at all
so his idea is just to round up all the
pawns yeah he just wants to keep three
and that's it
causes a resignation from the pomniachi
and
magnus once again is triumphant in the
armageddon and what a great
positional strategical game from magnus
carson you know he played that one
perfectly
and today today we can say that magnus
was in shape